ich bin ja jetzt quasi gezwungen meine
eigenen Süßigkeiten herzustellen und so
mache ich aus Obst Gummibärchen dafür
kann man alle möglichen Früchte
verwenden ich finde es aber besonders
lecker wenn noch ein paar Weintrauben
mit drin sind das ganze einfach kochen
und pürieren und dann ungefähr einen
halben Zentimeter dick auf Backpapier
ausstreichen ab in den Dörrautomaten
damit und nach ungefähr sechs Stunden
sieht das ganze dann so aus dann
schneide ich das mit dem Backpapier
zusammen in Streifen und Roll das auf
dann kann ich das nämlich in einem Glas
lagern ohne hinterher beim Rausholen
klebrige Finger zu bekommen